[Musik]
ich war stoppen und so und nein ich war
schon nicht michaels meine lieben
freunde heute soll es nicht um die
lappen gehen also einer gewissen form
schon denn ich blogge heute der heutige
flug soll sich voll und ganz um die neue
luca pizza 3 drehen
die habe ich nur leider gerade noch
nicht so klar vor einigen wochen hatte
ich schon so ein paar testexemplare von
kapitza 3 allerdings noch nicht die
finale pizza mit einfach die sonne
scheint was ist da los deutschland
sonnenbrand alexander du hast übrigens
einen ganzen fand er vergessen und einen
editor schuhe also vor einigen wochen
hatte ich schon mal einige imker pizzen
am start die sache war nur dass die halt
wie bereits gerade schon gesagt nicht
die finalen sitzen waren mit denen
komplette genauen finalen zutaten noch
nicht der finale karton allerdings
bekomme ich diese heute geliefert und
ich die gerade auf einem richtigen
küchenblock vor allen euren körper 3
allerdings weiter wir geliefert würde
ich sagen frühstück wer erstmal ganz
gesund und kulinarisch joghurt ist sogar
erheblich solist am liebsten soft moment
habe ich erst am liebsten die zinsmarge
wandert oder seid ihr so fruchtzwerge
menschen ist aber auch egal ich es auf
jeden fall meinen joghurt sahne auf und
dann sollte jetzt nicht waren
ehrlich mal vernünftig essen hier im
haus die ganze scheiße übertrieben da
wird schon ein paar sekunden später also
die pizza ist im eisfach allerdings ist
mir der schnittlauch runtergefallen aber
egal heute in new york wo fange ich denn
sonst sagen erst mal kurz dem ofen vor
bei 150 grad ober unterhitze die besten
voraussetzungen für eine kooperation der
sache die einige leute verwirrt haben
und zwar habe ich ja vor einigen wochen
in dem video sieht kapitza 3 gesagt dass
die pilze am 19 11 19 erscheinen wird
das beiden teams datum oder dachte ich
mir hey das ist cool allerdings haben
uns jetzt gegen den 19 11 19 entschieden
und für den ersten 12
da hat auch mein neues merchandise
rauskommen und dann kommt quasi alles
neue von loeb wird von uns zum
mecklenburg alles kommt dann legen wir
als zwölfter raus ist der erste advent
das heißt auch ganz cool ist auch ein
cooleres datum find ich tatsächlich als
der neunzehnte älter und die sache ist
allerdings was man auch sagen muss
es ist nicht so wie wenn man märz
herausbringen dass man auf den knopf
drückt und die seite ist online sondern
die pizza das sind halt hunderttausende
pizzen mit lkw durch ganz deutschland
das heißt es kann auch sein dass ist die
pizza bei euch schon in dem einen oder
anderen rewe gibt sind aber schon eine
person auf install angesehen die pfizer
tatsächlich schon gegessen hat bevor ich
überhaupt die karton gezeigt habe weil
damit wollte ich eigentlich bis kurz vor
release warten allerdings dass es mal
ganz kurz die erklärung dazu warum die
pizza jetzt eigentlich nicht am 9
heraus kamen sondern wirklich offiziell
erst am ersten zwölf allerdings sogar
schon gesagt das ist sehr fließend der
launch termin
das kann sie das bei euch im rede die er
am 17.12.09 ist oder jetzt gerade schon
dort verfügbar
die seien gerade auch ein instagram
filter für die blitzer 3 das hier ist ja
mein jetziger filter auf instagram wenig
gemacht haben wenn du die nutzen wollt
folgt mir gern aber ja also es kommt auf
jeden fall auch ein pizza filter dann
zur nächsten sache und es war ich noch
gar nicht so richtig den karton gezeigt
dann will ich mich auch wieder was neues
überlegt und zwar in euch einfach dass
der partie es ist sehr schlimm sehr
simpel und sehr weil wir haben uns
gedacht die pizza ist auch sehr clean
und sehr simple also das einzige was
wirklich auf der pizza drauf ist ist der
käse es ist also klar ist eine käse
soester noch mal drauf diese ricotta so
soll mascarpone aber dann halt ganz
viele verschiedene sorten käse oder so
eine richtige käse explosion hat und
halte auch zwiebeln ein bisschen für die
würze und für die farbe aber wir haben
auf jeden fall für den karton
entschieden
man sieht ja schon wenn man genau
hinguckt das ist sonst meine of print
wie bei den kattas damals lukas ott gab
und dann hier oben gustavo gustl open
stage ist das ist so ein bisschen wie
nennt man das geprägt ich weiß nicht ob
das auch der kameramann das richtig sie
wären im supermarkt sei dann spürte dass
schon das ist ein bisschen ein
hochwertiger druck ist eine saugglocke
tom ich wollte sich wieder ganz den
smiley drauf packen sondern eher die
pizza für das produkt sprechen lassen
und im fahrzeug übrigens fragt was der
richtige offizielle name der pizza ist
endlich als pizza bianca set informatik
oder falls es auch in folge noch deutsch
beantworten wollte sagt einfach es ist
eine traditionelle steinhofen 14 7
käsesorten frischen frühlingszwiebeln
und auch einfach die beste pizza der bin
dafür ist auch sinnvoll die vorderseite
des kartoffel auf der rückseite am
wetter da wieder hier sind kleinen
vollidioten hier bin auf jeden fall ich
und wir haben es auch wieder so gemacht
dass es nicht nur diesen karton sondern
es gibt viele verschiedene kartons weil
wir haben verschiedene bilder gemacht
die nach ich zum beispiel es gibt doch
bilder wo ich eine gemacht viel wissen
und machen die strecke alles gibt
jeden fall verschiedene kartons ms
allerdings auf jedem karton gleich es
ist natürlich klar die zubereitung des
empfehlung dann halt die aufbewahrung
die nährwertangaben und das hatte ich
alles schon gesagt das war bewusst so
produziert komplett klimaneutral da kann
man auch ein paar zwischen brega und auf
der rückseite steht auch wieder ein text
drauf treffen sich käse und laut sagt
der laut hallo käse sagte käser hallo
luca den habe ich mir überlegt ich habe
auf jeden fall noch von kleinen texten
beschrieben wie es zu der lücke bis zu 3
sparen und so weiter und so fort
allerdings ist das sie dann tatsächlich
auch dass der das werden das ist der
karton
ich hoffe euch gefällt euch dollar offen
ist werde ich vor gehaltes lassen jetzt
die pizza aus beton aus ich habe viel
zeit schon anschauen lassen in der zeit
wo ich euch ja den karton gezeigt haben
das würde ich euch auch empfehlen also
während der ofen vorheizen auf 250 grad
ober unterhitze einfach die pizza ein
bisschen an trauen lassen
ich hab schon wieder richtig hunger hat
jetzt das drin
das heißt wir warten jetzt 6 bis 10
minuten also ich mag halt immer noch
salz und ein bisschen pfeffer sogar noch
auf die kappe zwar drauf weil ich
vergleiche das die lukb ist drei mal ein
bisschen mit flammkuchen und ich erst
flammkuchen und so auch mal mit salz und
pfeffer
also ich muss sagen ob ich jetzt keinen
mehr viel zu sagen das ist 727 luca
pizza hätte ich jetzt gegessen habe ich
meine erhöhen die plötzlich auf den
markt bringen wenn die uns allen nicht
so gut schmecken würde
das einzige was noch zu sagen eines
kompletten vegetarisch sie sind nicht
vegan aber das kann sich auch jeder mit
einem normalen menschenverstand
kombinieren wenn der käse drauf ist noch
mal zur info die sieben käsesorten hier
auf der pizza drauf sind sind elementar
ladstätter gau damals erinnert die
karton mascarpone wir hatten auch
überlegt noch parmesan draufzupacken
aber ich hab's dann gebacken in münchen
mit parmesan und ich bin kein riesen
parmesan fans und alle die sich damals
gewünscht aber es tut mir leid aber ich
selber mag damals an halt nicht so gern
ja und halt braucht liebe weil die sehen
schön aus
die sind frisch wird sich und ich bin
ein lauf jahr freuen was kann man sonst
so zugetragen
es könnte sein dass sie bei euch jetzt
schon im supermarkt worden ist rewe und
edeka simmel ist auch im baumarkt glaube
ich ich kenne das nicht aber ein paar
leute von euch kannten das als ich erst
mal wenn die leute fragen mich auch
immerhin körpers ist mit der pizza 3 in
österreich oder in der schweiz ich hab
keine ahnung die der markt hat die
möglichkeit die luca pizza zu bestellen
also fragt gerne bei eurem supermarkt
des vertrauens nach warum sie so kapitza
drei eventuell nicht im sortiment haben
und dass sie das bitte schnellstens
ändern soll h m und jahr aber viel mehr
gibt sagt ich sehr gerne mehr zu sagen
die ist komplett hand geformt die sache
ist einfach ich kann euch jetzt noch
tausend dinge erzählen was tolles an der
luga witz und viel arbeit da drinsteckt
und keine ahnung was wenn sie euch aber
schlussendlich nicht schmeckt ist das
alles egal
also ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr
einfach mal bei eurem supermarkt dürfte
vorbeischaut oder ein paar tage danach
und einfach die pizza vielleicht mal
probiert er wird seine chance gibt das
wird mich sehr freue und jan eure
erfahrungen mit der ducati 23 mit uns
was ich mir dann auch noch überlegt habe
was wir heute noch machen könnten und
zwar ein stück der luca pizza drei unter
mikroskop anschauen
ich glaube ihr habt bereits im titel
gesehen das kann man da quasi darum ein
ich will jetzt einfach mal kurz die zu
der großen käm ich glaube das macht mehr
sinn wenn ich hier schon in meinem
aufnahme zimmer bin also wir schauen uns
jetzt di luca pizza dreimal unter dem
mikroskop an es ist jetzt natürlich kein
professionelles mikroskope 1000 euro
sondern
ist dass der käse was ist das
das sieht aus wie ein auge voller
schlange oder so ich bin das so ist wenn
man sich sachen unterm mikroskop ankommt
das war schlussendlich das was wir uns
gerade angeguckt haben sich schwarze war
dieses kleine stück da hatte dass das
kleine stück das war so ein kleines
stück pfeffer wenig darüber gemacht
haben aber gut wir schon mal weiter und
zwar auf den rand
das hier ist das ist moment kriegt das
noch das ist der rand freunde und ich
zeige euch mal meinen finger
das ist
das ist mein das sind diese diese rillen
auf guckt euch mal auch einen daumen an
dass diese rillen auf dem daumen und was
ich auf jeden fall auch noch unter
mikroskope gutachten wollte war eine
laut spiegel
diese
das ist nicht das durch die
lauchzwiebeln gewesen oder das ist die
lauchzwiebeln
was das denn das ist ach das war wieder
ein stück verfahren und dann gehe ich
jetzt noch mal direkt in die mitte von
der pizza also die verschiedenen
käsesorten haben das jetzt pfeffer das
ist einfach ein so ein kleines
pfefferkorn das sind alles kleine
verdienst dass sie ist der käse
ja das ist dann das ist dann wohl ein
bisschen fett hier
die sieht in echt so krass appetitlich
aus unterm mikroskop sind die raus
letztes stück scheiße also klar ich
meine das ist jetzt meine pizza und ich
will euch auch hier keinen vom pferd
erzählen natürlich möchte ich euch die
irgendwie schmackhaft machen und
verkaufen ist ja klar ich meinen gesang
an der pizza und ich feiere die auch
aber und damit grob sich alles hat immer
noch so ein bisschen alles sieht einfach
beschissen aus unterm mikroskop war das
ist meine hand und die sieht auch hart
kraft aus obwohl ich in echt eigentlich
der hottest mensch der welt bin als maul
können uns auch mal den karton mikroskop
anschauen ich will noch ein bisschen
erkältet das ist auf jeden fall der
karton dem körper drei habe ich euch ja
gerade schon gezeigt und sie jetzt ach
mein gott
was jetzt mal realtech ich suche euch
jetzt ganz nah ran auf die pizza kartons
beziehungsweise auf die gezeigte weder
irgendwo wenn ich jetzt dieses ding
davor halt so ein muster das mikro ist
eigentlich doch gar nicht so scheiße ich
meint mikroskop aber gut meine damen und
herren das auf jeden fall luca fischer 3
und am mikroskop und auf der lu kapitza
drei karton unter dem mikroskop an der
stelle mich dass heute wieder allerdings
auch beenden ich fange es auf jeden fall
mal ganz gut dass ich noch ein paar
fragen eingegangen bin also auf die
sachen die am meisten gefragt wurden
und ich hoffe ich konnte euch einige
fragezeichen im kopf wegpusten fast kopf
und wegpusten hört sich irgendwie falsch
und meldet das heutige video auf jeden
fall gefallen da würde ich mich sehr
gerne bei einem daumen hoch von euch
freuen unter dem video schreibt mir gern
falls sie noch fragen haben luca pizza 3
und in die kommentare und ich
war das komische mikroskop dran
ja meine lieben freunde ich hoffe ihr
freut euch auf den ersten 12 da kommt
ihr nicht nur die luca pizza 3 raus
sondern auch neues merchandise und zwar
nicht nur sachen mit meinem lobe also
mit dem smiley drauf sondern auch dick
und doof menschen da ist wenn man ein t
shirt wo so gestrickt ist dick und doof
auf der brust und einmal ein richtig
heißer rudi in seinem etwas of wight ton
und mit ganz näher und gewinn dick und
doof drauf ist auf jeden fall auch am
ersten 12
also möchte ich euch den ersten zwölf
ganz ganz ganz ganz toll in eurem
kalender ab jetzt da kommt raus und
neues merchandise hier oben stand ich
als ein werbevideo weil das pixel weil
das pizza hut über video gehandelt hat
weil das video beim eine pizza gehört
hat und ich will da rechtlich team seien
deswegen werbe video das alles hier
verfärbungen ich hoffe das video hat
euch gefallen abonniert game einen kanal
[Musik]